and out of hell the musical is set to
debut at paris las vegas on september
27th and one of the stars of the show
playing strat is joining us today
welcome travis quorum yay how are you
doing very very good straight from
canada
down to las vegas how are you adjusting
man it's uh it's pretty crazy i'm so uh
so happy to be here
it all happened so fast and i'm like man
what am i doing in vegas yeah you're
playing the lead in this new musical
tell us a little bit about the musical
yeah so
man it's uh
for me being like such a big meatloaf
fan this is so so cool
um you know i get to
i get to honor like the great work of
meatloaf and jim steinman and this
musical is just like so it's like this
rocky horror
romeo juliet kind of vibe
and um i get to play strat which is like
this rebel kid leader of a gang called
the lost
and the lost is like a gang of outcasts
um that found each other it's kind of
like
brotherhood
and uh strife always in love with raven
that her dad falco like rules the city
and like hates the lost and and and
strat and so there's like this war
between
strat and falco and this love story
between
uh strat and raven and then like the
whole brotherhood of the lost and in
between all that
there's just hit after hit of like just
amazing music and there's fire and
motorcycles and pyro and everything that
makes a great rock and roll show so
i'm just so stoked to be a part of this
talk to me about some of meatloaf's hits
uh it's i know it's probably impossible
to just pick one but what is your
personal favorite
oh god um it's really hard i mean i
think my favorite one to sing would be i
would do anything for love
that seems like a very hard song to sing
i try it in my car and it's not good
yeah did you ever try in the shower no
does that help yeah it has like a great
reverb in there you'll sound like
meatloaf does this have an echo can you
try it again
i would do
anything for see no i'd rather see you
i'd rather see you for sure we're really
excited about this so the show starts on
the 27th yes and uh are you nervous um i
think i'm more i'm more excited yeah
like i i can like barely sleep at night
um this is just such an incredible
opportunity for me and i just i'm really
committed to doing the best job that i
can we can't wait to see you you're
going to be fantastic and also being
from canada just found out he's also a
hockey fan you played hockey i played
hockey you got to go to a golden knights
game they play right across the street
from you i know i know don't tell people
in montreal but they're my favorite team
oh we won't tell send this to everyone
you know in montreal no i'm just kidding
thank you so much travis so great to
have you on the show thank you bad out
of hell the musical debut september 27th
and
we'll perform tuesday to sunday go see
travis tickets are available now and you
can purchase them at ticketmaster.com
and bat out of hell
vegas.com kendall travis